[Musik]
zdf heute live herzlich willkommen wird
querdenken ein fall für den
verfassungsschutz
die rufe danach werden jedenfalls immer
lauter spätestens seit sich der
stuttgarter gründer von querdenken
michael ballweg mitte november offenbar
mit anderen querdenkern mit reichs
bürgern in thüringen getroffen hat der
präsident des thüringischen
verfassungsschutzes rechnet jedenfalls
damit dass die bewegung bald als
verdachtsfall eingestuft werden könnte
die frage ist wie radikal ist quer
denken und wie gefährlich sind
diejenigen die es organisieren und auch
die die in teilen bei den
demonstrationen mit laufen zum beispiel
bei der demonstration am 18 november in
berlin mehrere tausend menschen haben
dagegen die korona politik demonstriert
weil sie sich nicht an die auflagen
gehalten haben hat die polizei die
demonstration schließlich aufgelöst
wir erinnern uns auch wasserwerfer waren
im einsatz allerdings nur mit
bewegungsfunktionen mehr als 300
personen wurden festgenommen und zehn
beamte wurden verletzt
das alles hatte begonnen in stuttgart im
frühjahr diesen jahres und genau dort
ist unsere korrespondentin eva schiller
schön dass du heute abend bei uns bist
eva wie ist die tendenz in baden
württemberg im moment in politik und bei
den behörden beobachten ja oder nein
ja da ist noch so ein bisschen
unentschieden also heute hat ja der
verfassungsschutz das parlamentarische
kontrollgremium den sogenannten
geheimdienstausschuss im stuttgarter
landtag informiert was genau da
besprochen wurde wissen wir nicht diese
sitzung hat geheim stattgefunden
danach hat aber der vorsitzende von den
grünen gesagt dass er sich schon
vorstellen könnte dass die querdenker
ball zu einem prüfer werden könnten
aber genaueres mehr haben wir aus der
sitzung noch nicht erfahren die afd
nur soviel hat schon mal gesagt dass sie
dafür
überhaupt keine gründe sehen aber das
ist ja auch ziemlich verständlich dass
es so kommt von der afd
dann schauen wir uns mal an was im
moment heute so auf dem tisch liegt an
begründungen und argumentationen dafür
querdenken genauer unter die lupe zu
nehmen und auch was die bewegung selbst
dazu sagt es ist eine mischung von
strömungen die sich bei den corona demus
zeigt friedens flaggen
reichskriegsflagge hinweise auf
verschwörungs mythen auch wenn eine
führungsfigur der querdenker der
stuttgarter michael ball weg sich von
extremisten distanziert wir sind eine
friedliche bewegung aber so klar ist der
abstand möglicherweise nicht bei big und
die querdenker trafen sich zum beispiel
mit dem november mit polizeibekannten
reichs bürgern auch mit einem selbst
ernannten könig von deutschland für
christian kreis der anlass sich
loszusagen
mir ging das zu weit ja sich mit einem
im königreich deutschland mit 1 peter
den ersten zu treffen
das war für mich so eine linie mit nein
da kann ich nicht mehr mitgehen
vorgänge die auch die
verfassungsschutzbehörden auf die
bewegung schauen lassen
interessanterweise finden wir in der
zwischenzeit eben bei vielen querdenker
organisatoren auch bundesweit bekannten
personen genau diesen reichs bürger
sprechtext rehm ist ische parolen die
sprüche der selbst verwalter und reichs
bürger werden von teilen des
demonstrationsgeschehen es übernommen
das zeigt dass die strategie der
extremisten auch ein stückweit
erfolgreich ist so werden die rufe
lauter der verfassungsschutz möge
genauer hinschauen nicht auf friedliche
demonstranten
aber auf extremisten wurde den
querdenken genau die frage wie sind denn
die anteile von extremisten und normalen
bürgern unter den querdenkern dazu
kommen auch schon hier im chat viele
fragen sie willkommen hat zum beispiel
schreibt über facebook nicht jeder der
die aktuelle lage kritisch sieht ist ein
sogenannter propagierte querdenker hier
wird die gesamte kritik aus der
menschheit in einen topf geschmissen
eva wie ist deine einschätzung ein
würden baden württemberg wie setzt sich
diese bewegung da zusammen
ja ich muss sagen in teilen ist es schon
auch mein eindruck wir sind von anfang
an bei den dänen muss dabei gewesen und
da war schon eine ganz große mehrheit da
würde ich sagen die steht in der mitte
der bevölkerung da waren viele familien
dabei gerade hier in baden württemberg
waren viele menschen dabei die das
impfen sehr kritisch sehen die sich da
sorgen machen
es gibt auch eben sehr sehr viele eltern
denen die masken pflicht zu weit geht
also es gibt da ein ganz breites
spektrum und ich glaube was ich wirklich
sagen lässt dass sich diese menschen auf
keinen fall einer politischen richtung
zuordnen lassen
da ist links da ist mitte da ist rechts
und unser eindruck war schon das im
laufe der zeit diese demonstrationen ein
stückweit gekapert wurden immer mehr von
extremisten von reichs bürgern von
rechtsextremen
daneben auch von mitgliedern der afd die
auch dabei waren also am anfang war
unser eindruck dass es eine
protestbewegung war und das hat sich
dann im laufe der zeit verändert ich
würde aber immer noch sagen dass
zumindest hier in baden württemberg ein
ganz großer teil auch aus der mitte der
bevölkerung kommt das ist in baden
württemberg vielleicht besonders wert
mal hinzuschauen der antisemitismus
beauftragte von wirten baden württemberg
dr michael blume hat das heute getan und
sehr spezifische baden württemberg
erläutert warum er glaubt dass die
bewegung da so erfolgreich ist und
blickt dabei weit in die geschichte
zurück
ursprünglich wollten württemberg bayern
und sachsen gar nicht zum deutschen
reich gehören die sind da rein gezwungen
worden und schon im neunzehnten
jahrhundert hatten wir hier und in
leipzig die großen antik bewegungen soll
das sind alte traditionen pietismus
anthroposophie der obrigkeit kritik und
misstrauen gegen berlin sind leider in
süddeutschen noch sehr stark max otte
hat davon gesprochen dass das bargeld
abgeschafft werden sollte das
funktioniert in schwaben immer gut als
verschwörungs vorwurf und jetzt kommt
dann eben noch dazu dass zum beispiel
die verfassungsgebende versammlung ein
gerufen wurde durch den michael ball weg
es wird sich mit dem reichs bürgerkönig
getroffen also da muss sich schon fragen
wer es jetzt noch nicht sehen will wie
gefährlich diese bewegung ist und wie
die sich radikalisiert der möchte es
offensichtlich gar nicht wahrnehmen
tja so weit michael blume gute kaputt
schreibt auf facebook wer mit neonazis
zusammen in eine richtung auf derselben
straße marschiert der muss sich fragen
gefallen lassen
nun hat herr blume gerade sehr viele
gruppen genannte ja unverdächtig sind
pietisten anthropologen auch leute die
in der esoterische richtung gehen das
ist ja alles total okay und auch du hast
gerade schon viele verschiedene gruppen
genannt
die du getroffen hast menschen mit
verschiedenen überzeugungen auf diesen
demonstrationen was alle vereint diese
menschen also ich glaube was diese
menschen vor allem vereint sind
feindbilder auch wenn diese feindbilder
wiederum sehr unterschiedlich sind also
wie schon gesagt für die einen ist es
eben das impfen den anderen sind diese
strikten corona maßnahmen aus berlin
dann irgendwie doch zu strengen sie
fühlen sich in ihren rechten
eingeschränkt in ihren freiheitsrechten
und ich glaube was was noch dazu kommt
zu dem was herr blume da sagt ist dass
das land ja auch sehr pietistisch
geprägt ist eben von dieser starken
protestantischen bewegung man ist sehr
obrigkeit kritisch das haben wir ja auch
gesehen wenn stuttgart 21
demonstrationen und ich glaube dass es
auch nochmal so ein grund warum hier so
viele menschen auf die straße gehen eben
ist dann auch sehr viele
friedensaktivisten dabei sehr viele
menschen die eben auch diesen et also
esoterischen dingen anhängen immer
wieder sagen also das sei irgendwie
indianische bekomme
leute die irgendwie in der indianischen
kultur nahe stehen andere esoterische
friedensbewegung und viele homöopathen
also es ist wirklich so ein ganz unter
mix der da gemeinsam auf die straße geht
und die sich nicht so richtig gehört
fühlen von berlin und ich meine wie die
wie die userin ja gerade geschrieben hat
wer mit neonazis demonstriert muss sich
fragen gefallen lassen umgekehrt muss
man natürlich auch sehen dass wir
einfach so bei den querdenkern
demonstrieren möchte das eben auch sehr
schwer hat weil da eben diese leute an
der spitze sind die sehr extreme
positionen vertreten genau den punkt
werden wir im weiteren verlauf des chats
noch vertiefen können an dieser stelle
vielen dank eva schiller für seine
beobachtungen und einschätzungen aus
stuttgart und wir schauen uns gemeinsam
an wie dein kollege simon pfanzelt die
situation dort zusammen fasst die
entwicklung aus dem frühjahr aus einer
kleinen gruppe in stuttgart bis hin zu
demos in berlin und leipzig jetzt im
herbst mit mehreren tausend menschen
stuttgart hier hat die querdenker
bewegung ihren ursprung im mai
demonstrieren tausende menschen darunter
auch viele familien und unternehmer die
mit dem corona maßnahmen nicht
einverstanden sind und wer sich schützen
will kann sich schützen aber damals 83
millionen gesunde menschen in quarantäne
zu schicken und zusperren und die
wirtschaft runter zur last es ja was es
gab es noch überhaupt
es kommt zu querdenker demos im ganzen
land und teile der bewegung werden immer
radikaler in berlin überwinden
demonstranten die absperrungen vor dem
reichstag stürmen die treppen vor den
gebäuden in leipzig demonstrieren
tausende dicht an dicht und ohne masken
später eskaliert die situation
es kommt zu ausschreitungen dazu
geschichtsrevisionistische vergleiche
wie hier in hannover
und ich fühle mich wie sich durch so
viel scheiße da ich seit monaten ihr
aktiven rechtsextremisten reichs bürger
und antisemiten dominieren mehr und mehr
das demonstrationsgeschehen das ruft
verfassungsschützer auf den plan
es geht nicht mehr nur darum dass
vielleicht ein paar spinner irgendwelche
populistischen radikalen forderungen
äußern sondern dass die brücken hier in
die vor allem bürgerliche mitte
funktionieren hier immer mehr anschluss
gefunden wird auch an die
extremistischen ideologien und insofern
müssen wir uns als verfassungsschutz
gedanken darum machen wie wir mit dieser
gesamtkonstruktion umgehen
wir machen dazu direkt weiter mit
matthias queck der soziologe und
gründungsdirektor des instituts für
demokratie und zivilgesellschaft in jena
schönen guten abend advent sie haben den
beitrag gerade gehört sie forschen vor
allem zu rechtsradikalismus
radikalisierung und hasskriminalität
teilen sie die einschätzung von herrn
kramer was ist aus ihrer sicht zu tun
aus sicht des verfassungs also aus ihrer
sicht was sollte der verfassungsschutz
am besten tun beobachten ja oder nein
die frage der beobachtung dieser
bewegung stellt sich ja nur so halb weil
sich die bewegung sowieso schon
überlappen mit antidemokratischen
rechtsextremen bewegungen
ich will aber zwei sachen dazu sagen
dass eine dass das einen
nachrichtendienst natürlich nicht
geeignet das gesellschaftliche konflikte
aufzulösen die sie sich auch hier
manifestieren und das zweite ist dass
diese
bewegung die sich dort auf der straße
bahn brechen auch wenn es keine reiche
bürger keine neonazis sind doch
hochproblematische für die demokratische
kultur hochproblematische position vor
sich her tragen also anthroposophen mit
einer tendenz zum antisemitismus auch
impfkritiker die attraktion aale
diskurse die die wissenschaft ablehnen
da sind ja allesamt an die
aufklärerische bewegungen wie dort
zusammenkommen
die müssen nicht rechtsextrem sein aber
sie sind in einen punkt in dem ihre
glaubenssätze die irrational sind so
sehr großen teil einfach
wissenschaftlicher unsinn sind heraus
als herausgefordert wahrgenommen werden
das aktiviert sie politisch bringt sie
auf die straße und auch bis hin zu
radikalisierungen wo dann der
schulterschluss mit noch extremeren
schon bekannten rechtsextremen
strukturen naheliegend ist aber das ist
sozusagen auch ein problem das wirklich
über sicherheitspolitische debatte
hinausgeht da müssen wir schauen was
gibt es eigentlich an ihre führenden
glaubenssätzen wo muss man da mit
bildung mit prävention oft wie früher
ansetzen
und wie geht man damit um genau ich
würde nur ganz gerne nochmal bei der
frage bleiben wie die annäherung
zwischen rechtsradikalen extremisten und
ganz normalen bürgern ist die sich dabei
quer denken versammeln jojo krieger
fragt bei youtube was ist denn der
genaue anteil an extremen ansichten in
der querdenken bewegung gibt es darüber
zahlen oder annäherungen
also man kann den leuten natürlich nicht
auf die körper in die töpfe schauen die
da demonstrieren gehen aber wir waren
seit april mittlerweile dass diese
proteste von rechtsextremen nicht nur
unterwandert werden sondern angeleitet
werden das heißt also mit den
demonstrationen erfahrungen mit den
narrativen mit bildern und insbesondere
in sozialen netzwerken insbesondere in
telegram wo also tausende zehntausende
menschen aus baden württembergern aus
baden württemberg in rechtsextrem
antidemokratischen gruppen aktiv sind
kann man auch tatsächlich ausrechnen und
zeigen wie hoch der antidemokratische
inhalte sind die wichtigsten zehn
accounts die am meisten geteilt werden
sind rechtsextreme verschwörungs
ideologische accounts die einfluss auf
die ideologie
bildung dieser gruppen nehmen das
bedeutet also man kann davon ausgehen
wenn sich zehntausende menschen im
internet in diesen gruppen umtreiben
bundes bei 100.000 dann werden
diejenigen die auf der straße sind auf
die straße gehen zu genau diesen
anlässen zu den demonstrationen die in
diesen gruppen geteilt werden auch von
diesem narrativen von diesen ideen dort
mit mobilisiert da gibt es
möglicherweise auch einige verwirrte die
aus legitimer kritik und nicht aus einer
kritik an dingen die überhaupt nicht
existieren demonstrieren gehen
andererseits muss man aber auch sagen es
gibt ja auch die demokratischen
kundgebungen von künstlerinnen von
gastronomie von anderen einrichtungen wo
die hingehen könnten
das heißt es gibt für mich keinen grund
anzunehmen dass der gesamt thrive diese
anti aufklärer dieser bewegung nicht
anti aufklärerisch und strukturell auch
rechtsradikal ist weil das sind die
dominanten negative die in der
mobilisierung und auch in den medien in
den sozialen medien eine rolle spielen
man könnte ja als demokrat seine eigenen
protestgruppen aufmachen wo nicht
irgendwelche kuh enden anspielungen wie
von herrn bei decoder so geteilt werden
das passiert aber nicht und im gegenteil
diese gruppen haben mehr und mehr zulauf
und da teile ich die einschätzung von
herrn kramer werden auch immer radikaler
können sie das ein bisschen genauer
beschreiben als wir haben von diesem
treffenden thüringen gehört wo genau
sind die schnittstellen zwischen reichs
bürgern und querdenkern dass sie sind
jetzt mal ideologisch in der ablehnung
der realität man will sich der
solidarität der gesellschaft entziehen
dem zusammenhalt der gesellschaft und
dann haben wir unterschiedliche
erzählung linien
die einen sagen deutschland gibt es gar
nicht die bundesrepublik derzeit die
legitime ist konstrukt und alles was die
bundesregierung mache sei in
wirklichkeit jüdisch kontrolliert oder
amerikanisch kontrolliert was in der den
chiffren auf dasselbe hinausläuft und
habe deswegen keine bedeutung für das
deutsche volk für die die im krieg
kritiker oder die esoterischen
corona rebell wie sie sich nennen
argumentieren ja ganz ähnlich sie wollen
nicht mitmachen bei dem was die mehrheit
der gesellschaft jetzt tut um diese
pandemie einzudämmen weil sie denken
kann gibt es gar nicht es sei gar nicht
so schlimm
oder aber die wirtschaft sehr wichtig
wichtiger als die menschen leben von
risikopatienten da gibt es
unterschiedliche innovative die zusammen
kommen die dann das wurde gesagt auf
sich in populismus treffen sich auch in
verschwörungsvorstellungen treffen die
der meinung sind es gibt größere geheime
möchte die irgendetwas böses mit der
bevölkerung tun wollten und ganz konkret
gibt es dann auf der operativen ebene
die zusammenarbeit wenn es darum geht
erfahrungen auszutauschen wie geht man
beispielsweise auch mit der beobachtung
durch den verfassungsschutz
es gibt also verschiedene verschiedene
parallelen verschiedene gemeinsame
diskurs linien die sich letztlich in
populistischen anti aufklärerischen und
antidemokratische positionen
wiederfinden insofern ist es nicht
überraschend dass es solche treffen
solche absprachen gibt
in wirklichkeit ist es überhaupt nicht
überraschend michael dick hat schon im
april gesagt er möchte mit dem chat mit
dem anführer der identitäten bewegung
der rechtsextremen identitäten bewegung
gerne ein videochat machen sprechen also
diese berührungspunkte sind seit langem
da sie nehmen jetzt zu auch die gewalt
förmlichkeiten bei den demonstrationen
zu aber so zu tun als wäre das jetzt was
neues was keiner wusste das ist im
hinblick der entwicklungen der letzten
monate seit april als diese proteste los
gehen im grunde nicht haltbar insofern
hätte der verfassungsschutz der auch
schon viel früher nach meiner sicht in
irgendeiner art und weise auch
hinschauen müssen jetzt schreibt jim
nicht im sondern jim thaler über
facebook querdenken ist kein stück
extremistisch ganz im gegenteil die
bestehen zu praktisch ausschliesslich
bürgerinnen und bürgern der bürgerlichen
mitte querdenken es zu 100 demokratisch
und steht für frieden freiheit und
demokratie
ja ich meine das kennen wir die npd hat
sich auch nationaldemokratische partei
genannt
tatsächlich ist ja auch ein großteil der
wählerschaft von rechtsradikalen
rechtsextremen parteien kommt aus der
bürgerlichen mitte das sind keine
skinheads mehr diese rumlaufen natürlich
kann man das in der sozialen schichtung
durchaus auch den zuordnen ja der
extremismus kommt aus der mitte der
gesellschaft das war ein
nationalsozialismus so das ist auch
heute noch so
insofern ist das schutzbehauptungen die
dadurch nicht wahr werden dass ich
ständig wiederholt werden
also diese phrasen von freiheit
grundgesetz verteidigen und so weiter
die stehe in einem krassen widerspruch
zu dem was hinter den türen zum beispiel
ganz öffentlich in sozialen netzwerken
kommuniziert wird oder auch was die
projektionen sind die man da tut also
wenn man freiheit behauptet und damit
impliziert deutschland sei nicht frei
beides fremd kontrolliert wird oder weil
es eine diktatur sei hier ist eine sehr
verbreitete rede art in diesen gruppen
ist dann ist das keine kritik mehr das
ist einfach völliger unsinn und das
board kann man sich dann auch nicht mit
solchen affirmativen begrifflichkeiten
wie der user das jetzt da gepostet hat
relativieren lassen wir würden gerne mal
reinhören in ein paar töne von der demo
in berlin im november und vielleicht
können sie da anhand dieser noten auch
noch mal ein bisschen beschreiben wie
sich die bewegung entwickelt hat vom
frühjahr bis jetzt in den in den winter
hinein gehören bahrain bin nichts
anderes mehr hilft so steht es in
artikel 20 absatz 4
dann wird widerstand zur pflicht das ist
alles nicht alles carola virus und da
ist wo sind die dort wo ich danke uni
habe dank im krankenhaus da ist alles
dabei
und das ist alles nur deswegen bin ich
hier viele friedliche menschen hier ihr
einfach nur für die rechte einstehen für
frieden freiheit und demokratie
ja das muss man vielleicht erst mal noch
kurz einordnen also zur frage wo die
toten sind heute melden die usa alleine
3000 tote innerhalb von 24 stunden
italien meldet 1000 und in deutschland
waren es den zweiten tag hintereinander
fast auch wieder 500 das dazu und zur
artikel 20 absatz 4 grundgesetz den
widerstandsrecht auf das sich viele jahr
berufen aus der bewegung können sie
vielleicht als experte noch mal was
sagen und darauf eingehen
gute beispiele dafür wie sich
rechtsextreme negative durchgesetzt
haben dass die bezugnahme auf das
widerstandsrecht im grundgesetz dass
dort tatsächlich steht aber überhaupt
nicht für solche situationen gedacht ist
und keiner da keine anwendung finden
kann in einem demokratischen stabilen
rechtsstaat sondern in einer punsch
situation beispielsweise wo die
grundrechte ausgehebelt werden und zwar
anlasslos pauschal und auch auf eine art
und weise die langfristig nachhaltig ist
all das ist hier nicht der fall
aber wir kennen diese parolen wir kennen
die von peabody kennen die von neonazis
die damit ihre taten begründen
das zeigt wie sich rechtsradikale
innovative tatsächlich den weg in den
mainstream gebahnt haben um dort
handlungen begründen zu können und auch
rechtfertigen zu können warum man zu
bestimmten vielleicht sogar radikalen
mitteln greift und dasselbe ist dir der
vorwurf der lüge das ist natürlich
völlig hanebüchen was dort passiert
und ausgesagt wird aber ist reproduziert
etwas was tausende von 10.100 tausende
vielleicht millionen menschen
tatsächlich glauben oder zumindest
behaupten zu glauben zum teil auch um
aufmerksamkeit um anerkennung zu
generieren das wissen wir dass
verschwörungs ideologien die man
inhaltlich nicht widerlegen kann weil
kein inhaltlicher kern daran war ist vor
allem auch den zweck haben sich selbst
aufzuwerten sich selbst zur reserve
realisieren also wieder zu einer
handlungsfähigen person zu machen in
einer gesellschaftlichen situation wo
man das gefühl hat kontrolle und
einfluss zu verlieren und es garantiert
aufmerksamkeit das gilt für die gesamte
bewegung wo ja sehr viele
selbstdarsteller dabei sind die sich
öffentlich produzieren und die damit
auch viel geld verdienen das darf man
nicht vergessen dass dahinter auch
spendenkampagnen stehen dahinter stehen
influenza accounts in sozialen
netzwerken bewegungs unternehmer die mit
dem verschwörungs erzählung die hier in
die masse getragen werden geld machen
und der da sozusagen diese angst auch
ganz gezielt antreiben denn solche
erzählungen irgendjemand hat gehört dass
irgendwo im krankenhaus und so weiter
das kommt aus diesen kanälen können sie
es noch mal ein bisschen aufdröseln sie
haben verschwörungs ideologen genannt
sie haben
die esoterik szene genannt wie kommen
die da zusammen und noch eine
anschlussfrage wie tragfähig ist diese
verbindung wenn diese pandemie
irgendwann so gott will vorbei sein
sollte also wenn das feindbild sozusagen
fehlt bleibt das trotzdem ein phänomen
oder glauben sie dass sich das dann auch
einfach wieder diversifiziert zum einen
kommen diese unterschiedlichen spektren
darüber zusammen dass man an mythen
glaubt dass man also die orthodoxie
sozusagen die realität abgelehnt und
stattdessen irgendwelche alternativen
antworten sucht die können ganz
unterschiedlich aussehen das können also
die ablehnung der schulmedizin seien
dann sucht man sich andere alternative
heilversprechen das kann die ablehnung
des politischen mainstreams seien dann
sucht man sich politische alternativen
also dieses dagegen sein hat schon auch
eine ein selbstzweck für sich und dann
spielt manchmal auch erst in zweiter
instanz eine rolle
wogegen man eigentlich ist und vor allem
wofür man es dann kommt das mythische
das verklärende dazu die ablehnung von
aufklärung und wissenschaft wir leben in
hochwissenschaftlichen zeiten die aber
auch immer mit dem wissen wächst der
zweifel sagte schon goethe dazu führen
dass es rückbesinnung gibt
mystifizierung gibt den wunsch
irgendetwas transzendente sin der
radikal in der realität zu sehen und das
kann dann sowohl durch also
marginalisierte oder marginale
religiöse strömungen durch sekten durch
verschwörungs ideologen oder eben durch
struktur ähnliche verschwörungs
ideologien mit politischem kerngeschehen
die häufig antisemitisch sind sowie
kennen und dann findet man sich irgendwo
in der ablehnung des mainstreams diese
ideen diese strömungen diese
gemeinschaften waren auch schon vor der
pandemie da und man kann in diesen
kanälen heute viel darüber hören es geht
nicht um kroner es geht und was ganz
anderes
und das ist der eigentliche kern die
ideologischen grundlagen diese absprache
der der demokratie dass des
demokratischen des
wissenschaftsbasierten das war auch
schon vor corona da die meisten dieser
gruppen die heute einfluss haben die
waren auch schon im vergangenen jahr
aktiv haben aber nicht diesen diesen
zuspruch gefunden wie jetzt mit dem
corona thema und deswegen glaube ich
zwar leicht aber erstens dass dieses
bewegungs spektrum nicht politisch
mobilisiert fähig bleibt über dieses
über die pandemie hinaus dazu ist es zu
diffus dazu ist es auch zu wenig fassbar
kohärent die werden sich nie langfristig
irgendwie organisieren können wir schon
gar nicht als partei oder etwas
ähnliches andererseits aber ist dieses
die mentalität an verschwörungen
beispielsweise zu glauben
das betrifft in die einstellungs studien
zeigen bis zu einem drittel der
bevölkerung die bereit sind an solche
mentalitäten anzunehmen das wird nicht
verschwinden und das wird sich dann
irgendwelche anderen themen suchen
irgendwelche anderen anlässen zum
beispiel bietet sich dafür die
ökologische transformation und der
klimawandel an das also als corona
leugnen das ist unscharfer begriff aber
wird genutzt aus corona leuten dann
klimaleugner werden und wir im grunde
dieselben diskussion die wir ehrlich
gesagt ja auch schon 2014 in der krim
krise mit einem ganz ähnlichen
mobilisierungspotenzial auch von
rechtsaußen bis zu denken
friedensbewegten schon damals auf den
straßen gesehen haben aber nicht in
einer anderen größenordnung dass sich
das um andere themen um neue themen
immer wieder auch kopieren wird und dann
muss man mal ein bisschen
ja abwägen wie relevant sind denn diese
strömungen jetzt wirklich für das
politische geschehen und sehe ich das
hier im chat sich sehr viele mit der
frage beschäftigen und das freut mich
sehr weil es halt eine sehr konstruktive
frage ist wie geht man damit um
wie kann man reagieren und so fragt zum
beispiel julia krieger auf youtube den
hat heute schon mal jetzt auch zweimal
wie kann man dafür sorgen dass solche
leute wieder normale ansichten vertreten
advent und kettwig schreibt über
facebook erkennt wie kann man präventiv
mit diesen entwicklungen umgehen in den
schulen zum beispiel manchmal mit der
letzten frage an weil das die hitze
besser zu beantworten ist was kann man
also präventiv tun
natürlich geht es um medienkompetenz
aber verschwörungs mythen sind nicht
durch die sozialen netzwerke entstanden
sie werden dadurch nun besser
transportiert und auch schneller
international verbunden
wir brauchen so etwas wie eine
bibliothek toleranz was bedeutet dass
das bedeutet dass sich widersprüche
aushalten dass sich widersprüche
aushalten zb in den unterschieden von
wiesen krone regeln zwischen
bundesländern wie sind coroner regeln
auch auf eine art und weise geregelt die
auch ich nicht nachvollziehbar findet
die man kritisieren kann dass man also
widersprüche akzeptiert dass man auch
widersprüche im zeitverlauf akzeptiert
dass sich dinge ändern dass ich zum
beispiel auch wissenschaftliche
erkenntnisse ändern und das dadurch
nicht ein ganzes weltbild zusammen
kriegt oder nicht dadurch alternative
welt erklärungen präferiert werden die
dann also dem chaos da draußen ja der
komplexität der wirklichkeit einen sinn
zu geben versuchen indem sie sehr
einfach
hierarchische und auch verklärende
erzählungen herbeigezogen werden es geht
also um soziale kompetenzen die in der
schule vermittelt werden müssen
bis hin zu einer aufklärung natürlich
darüber wie
auch akteure sollten die verschwörungs
ideologisch oder rechtsextrem oder auch
islamistisch auch islamisten nutzen
ähnliche strategien ihren gemeinschaften
versuchen diese gesellschaft krisen
auszunutzen
der zweite punkt ist schwieriger zu
beantworten also die frage wie erreicht
man solche personen denn ich glaube dass
ein guter teil dieser person nicht
erreichbar ist weil sie sich darüber
definieren sich von allen anderen
abzugrenzen und eine eigene meinung zu
haben das wird ja immer betont ich habe
eine eigene meinung nicht das meer nicht
der mainstream dass diese meinung
völliger unsinn ist unter
wissenschaftlichen gesichtspunkten dass
die nicht nachvollziehbar ist wenn man
nicht durch die brille dieser personen
schaut das ist also das ideologische
moment das stellt uns für eine
herausforderung das heißt natürlich muss
man auf privater ebene auf individueller
ebene schauen ob man kontakte herstellen
kann ob man dann über andere themen
vielleicht einen zugang findet aber
jemand der wirklich in solchen
glaubenssystem ist sehr lieb
bundesrepublik für eine diktatur hält
oder der meinung ist dass es corona gar
nicht wirklich gibt
ich glaube dass diese leute nicht ohne
weiteres erreichbar sind
dann stellt sich die frage für alle die
die gegen korona maßnahmen demonstrieren
wollen an denen ist ja auch vielerlei
kritik zu äußern gibt die wird ja auch
geäußert viele leute beschweren sich die
gastronomen sind unglücklich wegen der
sperrmaßnahmen die sperrmaßnahmen kann
man schon sagen wegen bis lockdown slide
die eltern sind völlig aus der tüte weil
den kultusministern seit zehn monaten
nichts besseres einfällt als zu lüften
also es gibt ja berechtigte kritik aber
wo gehen denn die leute hin wenn sie
demonstrieren wollen und dabei nicht
neben nazis stehen möchten ja das ist
das tragische dass die tragische
auswirkung von querdenken und ähnlichen
bewegung ist dass die die echten
probleme und die echten annan gegen
eigentlich verschleiern dass sie das
durch die irreführung und durch diese
aufgesetzten versuche das zu erklären
im grunde den den realen kern ziehen und
damit auch die möglichkeit die
gesellschaft besser zu organisieren der
umgegend entstehen gestehen allerdings
muss man auch sagen dass es in stuttgart
bereits ab april auch demonstrationen
gab von gewerkschaften die gesagt haben
also wir sind auch gegen negative
soziale folgen die gastronomie hat
demonstriert pflegerinnen haben
demonstriert kulturschaffende haben
eigene demonstrationen gemacht um für
ihre anliegen für also ihre materiellen
für ihre berechtigten anliegen zu
demonstrieren die reisebranche hat immer
wieder auch demonstrationen gemacht
jetzt kann man darüber streiten warum
die in den medien nicht so häufig
vorgekommen sind wie diese schrillen
verschwörungs ideologischen
rechtsextremen und zum teil auch
gewaltvollen demonstrationen aber es
gibt und das wäre tatsächlich auch mein
appell natürlich gibt es jede menge zu
kritisieren und besser zu machen aber
legitime kritik wird dann wenn man mit
solchen personen zusammen geht und
verein sich solche bewegung anschließt
die in der gänze in der gänze nicht mehr
auf dem boden von demokratischen werten
stehen auch wenn das leute die dort mit
laufen auch wenn die noch auf der
demokratischen werten wegen stehen aber
insgesamt bewegung ist das nicht der
fall dass die eigentlich ihre anliegen
ja ihre anliegen aus ihren anliegen
schaden wenn sie dort mitmachen und dann
muss man nach neuen beteiligungs
partizipationsmöglichkeiten suchen
eigene demonstration petition und so
weiter um sich eben nicht vereinnahmen
zu lassen
aber vielleicht auch noch ein zweiter
punkt ich glaube man kann auch im
internationalen vergleich auch
hinsichtlich beispielsweise dessen was
für die gastronomie in deutschland als
ausgleich getan wird darauf hinweisen
das ist ja so schlecht gar nicht gäbe
ist und bei aller kritik dass eine
pauschalkritik jetzt an der politik auf
zu kurz greift denn es wird ja durchaus
sehr sehr viel geld in die hand genommen
sehr viel getan um die krisenfolgen hier
zu überstehen wenn man in die usa schaut
wenn man in andere länder schaut da
träumen die menschen von solchen
verhältnissen wie wir sie hier in
deutschland haben erkennt ich möchte
gerne zum abschluss ohne die vergangenen
30 sehr interessanten minuten mit ihnen
in frage stellen zu wollen eine frage
zum abschluss übernehmen von unserem
user björn nazarov der über youtube
fragt schenken wir den querdenker nicht
einfach zu viel aufmerksamkeit einer von
zehn menschen hat tendenziell doch immer
ein
an der murmel ja das ist eigentlich ein
schönes schlusswort tatsächlich ist das
ein dilemma wie geht man mit diesen
szenarien um sie sind ja mit solchen
entwicklungen um mit solchen situationen
um schenkt man sie zu viel
aufmerksamkeit
andererseits aber merken wir erst sehen
wir sind der forschung zweitens kriegt
das kriegen dass viele menschen im
alltag mit das ist ja nicht darauf ein
extrem rand beschränkt ist sondern dass
solche ideen solche vorstellungen und
eine große unsicherheit durch familien
durch freundeskreise durch soziale
netzwerke wabert und es dort auch
durchaus ein wichtiges aufklärung zu
leisten in der art und weise was sich
aber in der tat problematisch finde ist
wenn so getan wird als sei diese
proteste jetzt eben das aufbegehren der
bevölkerung gegen die korona maßnahmen
das widerspricht allem was wir wissen
aus einstellungs aus meinungsumfragen
die mehrheit der bevölkerung findet die
die korona politik der bundesregierung
erfolgreich die menschen stellen sich
sogar wieder er hinter die etablierten
liberalen parteien und die
rechtsradikale afd verliert in den
umfragen insofern würde ich dem zustimme
wir dürfen denen die diese bewegung über
nicht aus den augen lassen und müssen
die gefährlichen potenziale betrachten
aber wir dürfen uns davon auch nicht
ablenken lassen von den echten
herausforderungen von den echten
problemen die die korona pandemie mit
sich bringt und die auch in den nächsten
monaten und jahren noch darauf folgen
werden sagt der soziologe mathias quandt
ganz vielen herzlichen dank dass ihr
heute abend dabei waren dankeschön für
ihre einschätzungen aus jena und ich
bedanke mich ganz herzlich auch bei
allen userinnen und usern fürs regel
mitdiskutieren und alle eure und ihre
fragen bis bald und allen noch einen
schönen abend